So, a famous example of classical conditioning is the Little Albert study. John
B. Watson, in 1920, wanted to see if we could classically condition a fear or a
phobia. So, he used a nine month old baby they called Little Albert. He let
Little Albert play with the white rat. And Albert loved this rat. He wasn't
scared of him at all. But then Watson would hit a steel pipe with a hammer to
create loud bang.
[NOISE]
And that would really scare Albert, it would make him cry and feel really
fearful. And eventually, after several pairings of this loud bang
[NOISE]
while Albert played with the white rat, Albert began to fear the rat. So, the
rat became the conditioned stimulus and the crying and the fear. Albert's
experienced was a condition response. So, it's sad that Little Albert no longer
like the white rat that he used to like. But here's the thing it gets worse,
Albert started to fear things that were similar to the rat, this is called
generalization. Albert generalized his fear to other furry things such as
bunnies, dogs, even Watson himself when he wore a rabbit mask. But the mask was
pretty creepy so I don't blame him. Now, it actually gets worse. Watson never
extinguished his fear so Albert had it throughout his whole life. There's
contradictory reports on what actually happened to Albert after the study from
he was a well adjusted adult to he died at a young age or he lived his life
with an extreme phobia of all furry things. But we just don't know. So, we
really don't want this to happen to Greg and have him be scared of the bell so
life so we need to extinguish his fear.